and it is a good evening from Washington  because we begin with some breaking news  check this out according to Politico  rabid open borders zealot congressman  luis Gutierrez will not run for  re-election from Illinois now the reason  for his decision is not immediately  clear it's a little strange little odd  surprise to me that's for sure if it's  true we're gonna update you if we learn  later more later in the show but I  remember the last time I remember seeing  him as he was being arrested at the  White House back in August of course  representing illegal immigrants his  community the illegal immigrants and he  said it represents but that is great  news